Just before you get started. I wanna head this off at the pass in the UK.
We pronounce this man as Vincent van Goff, not Vincent Vango.
I'm going with a British pronunciation throughout enjoy
Vincent van Goff was one of the greatest artists of all time,
but he just didn't know it.
Despite his struggles with mental illness,
he still produced some of the greatest work that anyone has ever seen.
What we all know about his famous paintings.
Few people know the intimate details of the man's life on today's biographics
we're gonna delve into the passionate life of Vincent vangogh.
It's impossible to live up to the deads,
but this is how Vincent vangogh began his life in a small village called groups
and debt in the Netherlands in 1853, his parents, Anna,
our Cornelia car Benes and theos van goth had a son who was still born,
who they named Vincent VI hem vangogh one year later her,
they had a second son and gave their new baby the same name growing up Vincent
would walk about with his mother and see his own name engraved on this dead
brother's tombstone.
Her mother seemed to be traumatized by the death of her first child,
and she was never afraid to tell the stories of how she lost him in her mind.
The real Vincent was this perfect little angel in heaven.
No one could possibly compare to him. Both his father,
Rens grandfather were ministers for the Dutch reformed church.
So it was a very strict household to be raised in Anna and Theo, Doris.
They went on to have two more boys and three girls.
Anna was most likely suffering from depression because she was never very loving
or affectionate with any of her children. She never gave them love or praise,
which made Vincent try his best to be deserving of the love.
He craved Anna was an amateur artist.
So she took her children into the fields and instructed them all to draw in
their sketchbooks.
Vincent loved to do this,
and he would even carefully take bugs and plants home with him so that he could
finish the drawing later.
Vincent was forced to leave school at a very young age.
They needed him to work a UN as possible. Luckily,
his uncle was an art dealer at a firm called Goup and C.
This was obviously the best kind of apprenticeship that Vincent Vango could have
hoped for.
He was surrounded by amazing works of art.
And part of his job was visiting museums to learn about the other great masters.
He taught himself to read and speak French,
German and English fluently so that he could sell art to clients all over
Europe. His brother Theo was also made to work for the same art dealership.
After completing his apprenticeship,
Vincent was transferred to one of the branches of the dealership in London.
When he was 20 years old, he moved into a boarding house,
owned by a widow named Sarah aler lawyer.
Her daughter usually was 19 years old. Vincent wrote to his family.
He was very happy in the lawyer house.
He wrote that he loved the hustle and bustle of London,
and he did the gardening and other TRUS to help the ladies around the house.
Now, this is where the story gets a little tricky.
The historians tell the story in a few different ways,
depending on the evidence that they find.
So I believe Vincent fell in love with the daughter <inaudible> since they were
only a year apart, others believed that he was actually in love with the mother,
which would be far more scandalous. This has intrigued people for years,
and there was even a play written about it called Vincent in Brickston where
they theorized that he fell in love with both of them, either way.
He proposed marriage to one of them only to learn that they were engaged to
other men. Vincent was shocked and tried to convince her to marry him. Instead,
he began to argue asking what was wrong with him.
Their arguments were so intense that he was kicked outta the boarding house and
told never to come back.
From age 20 to 23, Vincent started to read the Bible every single day.
And he put himself at a high standard of party customers visiting the Goup and
seed gallery were told not to buy the artwork. Obviously,
this is the exact opposite of what Vincent should have been doing at his jobs.
So he was fired.
He decided to follow an in his father's footsteps and become a minister.
And he found a job teaching at a Methodist school for boys.
He applied to the school of theology in Amsterdam.
The school required everyone to pass Latin exams. If he did not study enough,
he would punish himself by skipping meals or sleeping outside.
Considering that he was almost fluent in several Latin-based languages.
Vincent should have been able to pass the test quite easily.
Vincent Vango did not care so much about which church he belonged to.
He just wanted to preach the Bible to the poor.
So he went to the evangelical church of Belgium and he was denied as well.
In 1878,
he approached the church and volunteered to go to the coal mining towns in
Brussels, Belgium.
Most ordained ministers did not want to go there because it was one of the
poorest and dirtiest can immunities in the country.
But these are the peoples that Vango really wanted to help.
While he lived there,
he began to sketch the peasants while they were working in the coal mines.
The church had given him a comfortable house to live in,
but there was a local woman who was very sick and could no longer work.
She could not afford to pay her rents and to become homeless.
Vincent Vango took pity on her and gave the women his house.
He decided to go and live in one of the coal mining shacks. Instead,
there was no furniture in the shack and he was forced to sleep on the bare
wooden floor with the blanket.
The locals called him the Christ of the coal mines.
Even though the common people loved him, the church committee was humiliated.
They did not want someone who was living in squa to represent their religion.
So they decided to fire him
Without any real job skills to speak of.
Vincent decided that the one thing he truly loved to do was paint.
Instead of preaching about God and the passion he felt for the world,
he painted his emotions. Instead. Now 27 years old,
Vincent wrote a letter to his younger brother,
Theo explaining that he wanted have become an artist.
Theo was still working at the art dealership.
He knew that Vincent was truly talented and he encouraged him to pursue his
dream. He even offered to financially support his endeavors to become an artist.
They had an agreements that Theo would send Vincent 50 Franks a month for his
basic living expenses.
Vincent would then send a number of paintings to Theo who was allowed to keep
any profits he may have made from selling his brother's paintings in the
gallery.
He was incredibly grateful for the opportunity and would forego eating meals in
favor of buying more paint and canvases back then no one really knew the dangers
of lead paint. So he would use his mouth to wet his paintbrush,
which would've contributed to serious health issues.
Even though he resolved becoming a painter,
Vincent still had to push through his depression and his self doubt.
He once wrote, if you hear a voice within you said, I cannot paint.
Then by all means paint. And that voice will be silenced that same year.
Vincent fell in love with the wrong person for a second time.
His older first cousin Kiva Stricker that just lost her husband and was still
mourning his death.
Vincent proclaimed his love and proposed to marry her promising to make her
happy. Not surprisingly.
He left his home and fled to a parent's house in Amsterdam,
but Vincent wouldn't take no for an answer. And he followed her there.
Vincent confronted his aunt and uncle begging to speak with key because he
thought that he could ill convince her to become his wife.
He claims that he didn't need long to accomplish this and put his hand over the
gas flame saying that he promised he would stop talking when he couldn't stand
the burning of his flesh anymore.
They quickly blurred the flame and told him to leave.
Vincent moved to the Hague, which was the center of the dark art movement.
At the time at age 28, he completed his first oil pay and sent to Theo.
While living there, he met a prostitute named Cina Maria Hornick,
who was also called Sien.
She was an alcoholic suffering from syphilis and raising a four year old
daughter Sien was also pregnant with another man's child when she met Vincent.
So she could not work as a lady of the night yet. Again,
his heart went out to women who were suffering and he fell in love with her.
He wrote brother Theo that he enjoyed feeling like he was needed.
So Theo agreed to increase his monthly step end.
So Vincent could take care of her and the children financially C MBN modeling
for him as a subject in his drawings in a way,
this was very helpful because he could not afford to harm models,
but no surprises here. He caught both syphilis and gonorrhea from her.
The pain was so exc that he had to be hospitalized while he was in hospital.
CN had no loyalty to Vincent. She went back to selling herself on the streets.
Vincent Vango was already having issues with his mental health,
but syphilis is known for causing madness. When Theo learned about this scandal,
he threatened to cut off Vincent financially.
If he did not end his relationship,
he knew that Vincent had a huge heart that he was being taken advantage of.
So he was forced to break up with her and he left the hag
In 1885.
Vincent vangogh painted a piece called the potato eaters when he was 33 years
old today it's considered one of his first masterpiece because it truly captures
emotions of these farm workers.
And he had successfully captured the essence of the port.
He had hoped that his brother would be able to sell it because it was similar to
the dark paintings done by the Dutch masters. However,
it was not a popular style in Paris,
which is where Theo was living and selling the work.
They would send letters back and forth with Theo sketching out examples of mane
because their work was actually selling very well.
Vincent Vango had never heard of him, but it was intrigued to see the work.
Once he arrived in Paris, the, uh, brought him to the art gallery.
So you could see all the work that he had mentioned in the latter.
Vincent was blown away by the beautiful impressionist art movement.
Vincent immediately understood why the style was so popular and he swapped out
his dark hues for vibrant colors.
Theo also introduced him to various painters that are famous today.
Hiring a model was very expensive.
So he and his friends would pose for one another so they could practice.
This is why there are so many self-portraits of Vincent van Goff.
He often had no one else to model for him. So he had to look in the mirror,
his postman,
Joseph <inaudible> often agreed to sit and have his portrait painted too.
Getting into long discussions with van go. Most of the impressionist,
which only paint on days when the weather was beautiful,
they cared a lot about finding the perfect light.
They also understood the market really well,
so they could sell their paintings and make enough money to live for months.
At a time time, they would party and wait for inspiration to strike.
Vincent Vango was the polar opposite.
He had a very strong work ethic and he was willing to paint every single day in
order to get better at his craft.
This caused him to get into a lot of debates because he believed that none of
the other artists shared the same level of passion that he did. He once wrote,
I feel such a creative force in me.
I'm convinced that there will be a time when I will make something good every
day on a regular basis.
I am doing my very best to make every effort because I am longing so much to
make beautiful things, but beautiful things mean painstaking work,
disappointment and perseverance Theo often had to apologize on behalf
of Vincent's outbursts.
The only on artist in the group who actually felt inspired by Vincent's
determination was Paul Gogan.
He encouraged Vincent to loosen up and encouraged him to start drinking a green
liquor called absent. If you're unaware,
absence can cause hallucinations and it would've only contributed to more
problems in Vincent's mental health, always determined to improve his style.
He began studying Japanese art.
It was almost as if he could see the soul behind the painter.
So he felt determined to read books on Buddhist philosophy.
He wished that he could move there and told the other impressionist about it to
lose the track,
told him that the French countryside had a very similar look to Japanese
countryside and encouraged him to move there instead.
So he traveled to a town called Al.
It was truly beautiful and it motivated Vincent to paint even more than before.
Once he arrived in our Vincent found a yellow house with a very cheap rent of
just 15 Franks a month.
He spent most days painting an isolation surviving on a diet consisting,
mostly of cheap bread and coffee at night, he would absence.
There were points when he had absolutely no food.
So he started to drink the turpentine paint thinner and eat paint.
This began to do some serious damage to his nervous system.
And his mental state was in rapid decline.
Theo was worried about him and paid Gogan.
A step ends to live and work with Vincent in a,
when he found out that he was coming,
Vincent filled up the house with sunflowers so that it was bright and cheerful
for his best friend. He had been alone for so long.
He stopped painting under the influence of the other impressionist artists in
Paris. Now the work was completely original.
It was the best that it had ever been. Uh,
first Paul and Vincent were getting a along, just fine, his roommates,
but since Vincent's mental state was disintegrating,
he would initiate arguments with him and things became very uncomfortable.
Theo wrote a letter to Gogan that a few of his paintings had been sold in Paris
and sent him several hundred Franks during one, particularly bad fight.
Paul Gagan left the yellow house with his luggage,
announcing that he was taking the train back to Paris.
As he was walking down street of agan, her footsteps running behind him.
When he turned around, he saw Vincent vangogh holding an open razor blade.
The two friends froze and stared at each other.
Like deer caught in the headlights. In that moment.
Vincent snapped out of it and realized the insanity of what he was doing.
He turned around and ran away.
Paul Gogan hurried toward the train station and never spoke to Vincent. Again.
A few hours later, Vincent showed up to the local brothel.
The side of his face was bleeding. He handed one of the prostitutes,
an object asking how to take good care of it.
When the woman looked down in her open Palm,
she thought that he had handed her his own ear.
The police show of Vincent's house the next day.
And they took him to the hospital so that he could be treated for the open wound
where an ear used to be. When his younger brother Theo arrived,
Vincent was laying in bed and he began having seizures.
He was physically we and completely delusional.
Theo wrote a letter to their mother and sisters explaining that Vincent was very
sick and that he might die.
He wrote that he completely blamed him for not coming to visit Vincent sooner to
Jack on his wellbeing. After spending two weeks in the hospital,
or Vincent was released,
it returned to his small yellow house and felt very much alone.
Theo had waited until Vincent's recovery to tell him the news that he was
engaged. Her name was Joanna.
She was an accomplished piano player who gave public performances.
And she worked at the British museum Theo and Joanna both shared a passion for
the arts. And they were very happy together.
Instead of being happy about the news.
Vincent saw it as a sign that he would soon lose Theo's support.
And that would come a day when he would no longer spend time with him.
Gossip spreads like wildfire in a small town.
So the citizens of all were whispering about the air incidents.
They believed that Vincent van Goff was a threat to himself and others.
So they a petition saying that they wanted him to be locked in a cell in the
hospital. He wrote a letter to his brother,
Theo asking if he could be transferred to the St re asylum,
which would be a far more comfortable location than a cell.
He also sent him to large crates full of his paintings saying in a letter to
Theo that he knew his life as a painter was probably never going to happen.
And he hoped that he could become employed as a hospital orderly in the asylum
or any other job that he could possibly find,
but Theo never gave up on Vincent's talent.
He knew that the only thing that made his brother happy was painting.
So he paid for duke comfortable rooms, side by side.
One was used as his art studio and the other to be used as his living quarters.
The CI Remi convents in hospital had beautiful gardens,
which is where Vincent would go to spend. Most of his time painting.
He stayed sober and was fed three meals a day.
His physical health was finally beginning to improve. Finally,
after years of going on recognized,
Vincent van Goff received a letter from Theo saying that his paintings were
going on display in an arch show in Paris.
One of the paintings called the red vineyards sold for 400 Franks.
This was the first time that anyone had ever paid money for one of his paintings
and to put a small dent into reimbursing Theo for the money he had invested for
so many years,
Vincent had been afraid that marriage would come between his relationship with
Theo, but it was actually the opposite.
Joanna understood and supportive Vincent's Ark career as well after Theo and
Joanna got married and had their first son Vincent came to visit.
He had a gift for the baby, a painting called the blossoming almond tree,
which represented spring and new life.
As he held his tiny nephew in his arms for the first time they told him that the
baby's name was Vincent VI hem van Goff overwhelmed by the honor,
Vincent started crying, tears, joy,
and there truly was hope that things would get better
With all of Vincent's new hope and optimism about life.
Theo believed that his brother's health may have been improving.
So he helped him leave the asylum and find a place to live in the town of O he
shows an apartment living above a doctor named Paul Gache,
who was an amateur painter and a huge supporter of the impressionist movement.
Leo hopes that by living with Dr. Gache, he could live an independent life,
but still be close to medical care whenever he needed. Dr.
Gache knew that Vincent had gonorrhea and syphilis,
but he didn't know about his history of mental issues for a while.
Things seemed to, to be fine.
Vincent had dinner and pleasant conversations with Che's family and painted the
portraits of his new friends and neighbors on July the 27th,
1890 Vincent received a letter from Theo where he said that he was struggling
selling paintings that month.
He was simply venting and never said that he would stop helping Vincent
financially, Theo even included the usual 50 Franks,
but even the mention of financial difficult sent Vincent into a downward spiral
of self hatred. He felt he was a burden on the ones he loved the most,
and that they would be better off without him.
Vincent found a loaded pistol and walked out into the middle of a field before
shooting himself in the chest bleeding. And in shock,
Vincent realized that he was still alive. He had barely missed his heart.
He slowly stumbled back to the house where Dr. GE a began to operate
immediately. The doctor sent a message for Theo to call on the next train.
When he arrived, Theo found his brother sitting up in bed.
Vincent was covered in bandages and smoking his pipe Theo crawled into bed next
to his brother.
And they stayed up all night talking about the happy memories from their
childhood as they were falling asleep. Vincent said,
this is just like when we were home, please take me home.
Theo agreed to take him back to their little Dutch village as soon as he
recovered, but it would never happen. Vincent died in his sleep at 37 years old,
they covered his coffin in bright yellow sunflowers. Just six months later,
Theo died as well because he had secretly been suffering from syphilis two.
The brothers were buried side by side Theo's widow.
Joanna was left with almost nothing except their young son and a huge collection
of Vincent van Goff's paintings. As she went through his creative,
these so-called Reja. She found the Stary night,
which he had painted while looking out the wind at the mental asylum,
Vincent attached, a letter explaining the painting,
looking at the stars always makes me dream this simply as I dream over the black
dots, representing towns and villages on a map,
just as we take a train to get to TerraSol or Ru,
we take a death to reach a star.
We cannot get to a star while we are alive anymore than we can take the train.
When we are dead to die, quietly of hold, a age would be to go there on foot.
Joanna carefully, cataloged Vincent's work. She also collected his letters,
which is why we have so much information about the kind of person he was.
Joanna began to go across the continent to all the places where Vincent had
lived, trying to find any of his paintings so that she could keep track of them.
Most people had written Vincent doff as a madman.
So they'd either destroyed the paintings or given them away.
China was able to catalog over 2,100 sketches and pieces of art 860
of which were all paintings that does not include all the ones who were lost or
destroyed. Vincent van Goff's mother. Anna was still rejecting him.
Even after his death. She burns an entire crate of her son's work,
but she lived long enough to witness just how wrong she was.
And the entire work began to realize that he was truly a genius with Duran's
help. The paintings finally began to sell,
and his lifetime of prolific work supported his family for the rest of their
lives. Today,
van Goff's work is truly worth a fortune and the portrait to Dr. Gache sold for
$82.5 million. Even to this day,
his painting still fetched of millions of dollars.
He is considered to be one of the greatest painters of all time,
despite all of his struggles,
Vincent vangogh spent his life with passion and was devoted to the things he
loved. And even after attempting suicide, he still found a reason to live.
It is good to love. Many things for therein lies.
The true strength and whosoever loves much performs much and can accomplish
much. And what is done in love is done well.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up bottom below, and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos four days a week,
so hit that notification bell when you're subscribing.
So you find out about those also, why not check out our system channel graphics,
and as always, thank you for watching.